professor martin brazier walks the
galleries of the oxford museum of
natural history
he is the perfect stereotype of an
oxford professor shoulder length white
hair tweed jacket patch to the elbows
and the mysterious stain on his once
white shirt
the cabinets of the museum are arranged
chronologically and in his mind
professor brazier can step back through
time
mentally cloaking dusty bones with
scales feathers and fur to witness the
transformation of planet earth through
geological eons as he walks the
victorian museum
he is met first with the startling
variety of life on earth today
multicoloured birds take wing above
mammals in the trees reptiles on the
ground and fish in the water
further back are creatures that thrived
just a few thousand or million years ago
the dodo rubs feathers with the
ancestors of modern horses and the
lumbering woolly mammoths while our own
ancestral cousin australopithecus stoops
in the background
stepping further back through time
brings him suddenly to an age of mighty
dinosaurs a dynamic and varied ecosystem
sees vicious tyrannosaurs stalk across
the plains after armored ankley source
and miniature compsognathus fleeing at
their feet
tracing the evolution of these terrible
lizards further back into the
carboniferous it is not animals but
trees that rule the world
towering forests of lycopods stretch the
entire length of the pangaean
supercontinent while insects and
amphibians still cling close to the
water's edge
by the devonian 400 million years ago
the great diversity of life shifts from
the land to the seas as prehistoric fish
of every conceivable size shape and
color swarm the oceans
deeper in time the professor steps
across another extinction marked by a
flash of glaciation and the ocean
creatures transmute into simpler more
experimental forms
trilobites swim crawl and burrow
alongside tooth-shaped conadonts the
ancestors of vertebrates and saw-like
graptolites
reaching 540 million years into the past
he is
explosive radiation of experimental life
within relative moments the ancestors of
every living group of animals appears
sponges corals arthropods and worms all
jostle for dominance in the early
cambrian seas but even passing by this
explosion of biological innovation there
are wonders to be found
failed fractal experiments at
multicellular life are rooted on the sea
floor or inch across it through layered
mats of algae and bacteria
leaving cryptic marks in the sand that
will persist for 630 million years
and it is here that brazier's flight of
imagination
is met
with a wall of ice
a glaciation the likes of which the
earth has not seen since
the world-spanning big freeze persists
for 100 million years and beyond it
nothing more
the professor is brought back to reality
with a bump
the museum is packed to the rafters with
a dazzling variety of evolution and
geological history that spans the best
part of a billion years from the
neoproterozoic to today
but the events of the previous billion
years scarcely fill a single cabinet
nothing
it seems
happened
not just in the evolution of life but
also in the changing climate continents
and oceans
with a hasty glance at his watch martin
brazier steps out of the museum and
hurries across the courtyard to the
department of earth sciences next door
he is late for his lecture
today his students are eager to hear him
talk on one of his favorite subjects
the dullest period in earth history
when apparently nothing happened for a
thousand million years
but what was happening on earth for all
that time
and how could it stay the same
for so long
it is a time that brazier himself
affectionately dubbed the boring billion
but could nearly a quarter of earth's
history
really be
so empty
[Music]
this video was sponsored by
curiositystream the documentary
subscription service
we here at history of the earth are big
fans of factual content there's only so
many times you can watch squid game
before it's time you learnt about how
weird real-life squid are
one great documentary we've been
enjoying on curiosity stream is the
kingdom how fungi made our world
fungi a bizarre with some of the largest
and oldest organisms on earth making up
its alien kingdom we'll be covering
their origins soon so this documentary
is a great way to prime your knowledge
curiosity stream is a bargain at less
than 20 dollars a year and has a wide
range of documentaries on topics ranging
from science to music nature to sports
with new shows popping up every week so
head over to curiositystream.com forward
slash history of the earth to sign up
and using the promo code history of the
earth will save you 25
bringing a full year down to 14.99
just over a dollar a month
[Music]
two figures labor up a rocky hillside in
the wild country of sudbury ontario
[Music]
they are heavily laden with bulky
rucksacks and more equipment than anyone
could need on this summer's day
as they walk they narrate their progress
into microphones commenting on the
terrain the rocks they see and their
interpretation of the landscape
it is a bizarre activity but a necessary
one for these two men
for they are john young and charles duke
dit is 1971 and in eight months time
they will be doing the same thing
on the surface
of the moon
this is a training mission for the two
apollo 16 astronauts with dummy
equipment designed to imitate the heavy
spacesuits that will keep them alive on
their mission but their primary goal is
to analyze the rocks around them and
learn to recognize the signs of
meteorite impact when they see them
because this lunar landscape nestled to
the north of great lake huron was indeed
formed by an impact some eighteen
hundred million years ago
[Music]
the layered seafloor rocks on the barren
hillsides have been shattered melted and
flung eight hundred kilometers from
their origin leaving behind a crater
that was once 200 kilometers across
it is the third largest such crater on
planet earth and the astronauts
speculate that it was created by a space
rock some 15 kilometers across twice the
height of mount kilimanjaro geologists
believe this behemoth to have been an
icy comet which may have been flung
inwards from the frigid outer reaches of
the solar system many millions of years
earlier
there are many unknowns surrounding an
impact crater that has sat at the
surface of the earth for so long
but one thing is certain
this
was the last exciting thing to happen to
the planet
for a billion years
the astronauts who trudge along the
crater's shattered and deformed rim are
only able to gather information with
their eyes and cameras but more
sophisticated analysis of these and
younger rocks will reveal concentrations
of each element within them and the
proportions of those elements belonging
to different isotopes
carbon and oxygen among others both have
light and heavy forms that behave
differently under the various biological
and physical processes so by analyzing
the isotopic composition of the ancient
rocks geologists are able to reconstruct
the average conditions of the time
including atmospheric composition and
global temperature
and long after the sudbury-trained
astronauts put their knowledge to use on
the moon earth-bound geologists were
still piecing together the deep history
of our own planet using these isotopes
and in 1995 harvard geochemist roger
buick revealed unexpected results from
the rocks of northwestern australia that
seemed to show a shocking pattern
[Music]
the carbon and oxygen isotopes from
between 1.8 and 0.8 billion years ago
just stayed
the same
he and his co-authors had examined the
australian rocks with high precision and
they reconstructed an isotopic timeline
that simply flatlined this was in sharp
contrast to the isotopes of rocks both
older and younger than these which
varied much more widely as a result of
global environmental changes
but for this billion years the elements
in the rocks were unanimous
everything just stayed the same
this result was corroborated around the
globe and was so remarkable that it
prompted buick to paraphrase winston
churchill
never in the course of earth history
did so little happen
to so much
for so long
[Music]
1.8 billion years ago
the earth had barely emerged from the
world spanning huronian glaciation
caused by the emergence of oxygen
producing photosynthesizers in the
oceans when the sudbury comet blazed
through the skies to smash mercilessly
into the canadian shield
but once the dust from this catastrophic
impact had settled the global climate
remained remarkably warm until a billion
years later another tremendous
glaciation gripped the planet from its
poles to the equator for a billion years
between these gargantuan ice ages earth
basked in average temperatures that were
four degrees warmer than they are today
summer days at the equator reached 30
degrees celsius while polar waters
remained ice free some sea ice may have
formed during warm wet winters but there
were no permanent ice sheets on the land
or oceans geochemists face some
difficulty in explaining such warm
conditions at this point in earth's
history at the beginning of the boring
billion the sun is less than two-thirds
of its current age and is some 15
percent less luminous
casting that much less light and heat
across the void of the inner solar
system to warm the planet so it seems
likely that the atmosphere contained
gases that could trap that weak
illumination and hold it close to
swaddle the earth to greater
temperatures as man-made greenhouse
gases do today
but what were these gases
carbon dioxide in the quantities needed
to create such balmy conditions would
have dissolved into the oceans to turn
them acidic but there is no record of
this methane would have the power to
warm the earth with much lower
concentrations but since life is the
only known source of sustained methane
production there is no record of the
necessary bacteria in sufficient
quantity to make the necessary impact
so geochemists invoke more exotic
greenhouse gases
nitrous oxide which we know as laughing
gas may be one such component if it were
elevated to 10 times its modern natural
levels it could be enough alone to warm
the mesoproterozoic earth and keep it
warm for a billion years
meanwhile on the latin surface this vast
period saw the reins of two gigantic
supercontinents
colombia and rodinia
[Music]
although no supercontinents have existed
since the breakup of pangaea 175 million
years ago
geologists have nevertheless rewound the
tape of plate tectonics to see
continental masses drift together and
break apart several times over many
hundreds of millions of years
these so-called supercontinental cycles
usually bring about global changes in
ocean and atmospheric conditions as the
uplift of mountains and rifting of
basins changes the pace of rock
recycling worldwide
so it is surprising that a period of
such stability during the boring billion
encompassed the transition from one
great supercontinent to another
yet the change from colombia to rodinia
about 1.2 billion years ago was unlike
any other supercontinental
transformation
reconstructions from surviving fragments
revealed that colombia only went through
minor changes to become the new and
improved rodinia
some regions rotated some slid along the
outer perimeter but there was not the
wholesale shattering and dispersal of
fragments we would expect
without extensive rifting or collision a
single contiguous landmass remained in
situ across the mid-latitudes for a
billion years
and with all the continental pieces
gathered in one hemisphere of the globe
the rest of the world was given over
to vast ocean
but it was a very different ocean to the
one we see today
or the one that dominated through
earth's earlier years
donald canfield was a curious child
constantly hounding anyone who stood
still long enough with questions about
how the world worked
taking holidays at a cottage in the
florida keys the canfield family donald
his father and his grandfather would
spend days fishing in the azure waters
and it wasn't long before the
inquisitive young man would develop a
fascination with the ocean at the tender
age of 13 he vowed to dedicate his life
to the studies of our seas and 40 years
later was elected to the national
academy of sciences thanks in part to
his revelatory theories on the ocean
chemistry that turned the seas
black
during the boring billion
earlier ocean sediments dating to the
time of the great oxidation by newly
evolved photosynthesizers are defined by
widespread banded iron formations
these striped red and black deposits
represent the pulsing oxygenation of the
ocean as that oxygen reacts with iron in
the water to rain out red iron oxide all
over the world
but during the boring billion these
formations are gone there is no iron
oxide being deposited anymore and little
evidence even of oxygen in the deep
waters for a billion years
what happened to the global super ocean
all this time
donald canfield pieced together the
evidence from billion-year-old rocks and
modern-day ocean chemistry to paint a
radical picture
of a very unfamiliar ocean cold water
flowing off permanent ice sheets today
generates dense so-called bottom waters
that sink to the abyss and power a great
circulatory conveyor to mix sea water
between ocean basins and between the
surface and the deep
but during the relative warmth of the
boring billion no such ice sheets could
persist putting a stop to cold sinking
bottom waters and bringing the ocean
conveyor to a grinding halt
the seas became stratified from top to
bottom with very different conditions in
different layers
through the ocean depths
canfield suggests in what has become
known as the canfield ocean model that
instead of oxygen reaching the ocean
depths to stop the formation of banded
iron formations it was the presence of
another compound hydrogen sulfide that
blocked the creation of these
distinctive layers in the deep ocean the
warm surface waters lit by the sun and
able to exchange gases with the
atmosphere are still full of oxygen and
oxygen loving organisms
but at greater depths there is a sudden
change to stinking sulfidic waters
driven in part by bacteria that colonize
the boundary to convert sulfate to
sulfide where oxygen concentrations are
too low
hydrogen sulfide the gas responsible for
giving rotten eggs their distinctive
smell fills the ocean depths and reacts
with iron to make pyrite
fools gold
instead of red banded iron oxide and so
the sea floor is covered with a stinking
black sludge
that turns the entire ocean
dark
this stagnant super ocean persists for
the duration of the boring billion and
suggests that oxygen levels after the
great oxygenation event may not have
been as high as we once thought
the oxygen lovers that brought about
their own destruction now only cling on
in a thin surface layer of mere meters
atop a wreaking fetid murk many
kilometers thick
it may sound inhospitable
but life
as it so often does
finds a way
slow weathering from unchanging
continental masses and low atmospheric
oxygen means that few nutrients are
delivered to the seas so there are not
enough essential minerals to sustain
life throughout the oceans
nevertheless along the shores of the
eternal supercontinent there is enough
for microbial life to scrape by but it
is still an ecosystem dominated by the
simplest kind prokaryotic bacteria two
billion years after they emerged these
bacterial cells are still the masters of
the earth
they may be simple but they are by no
means the same different bacterial
metabolisms allow communities to thrive
in the varied geochemical zones of the
canfield ocean and reinforce it in turn
but the stagnant oceans of the boring
billion gradually become depleted in one
element that is essential for all life
nitrogen
some bacteria have the ability to
extract and use nitrogen directly from
the air but it is the lack of this
bioessential element that holds back the
rest of evolution paleontologists
believe that the more complex eukaryotic
cell had already emerged before the
boring billion began
but compared to the proliferation of
bacteria after their first appearance
the eukaryotic revolution struggles to
find its feet their greater complexity
makes for greater need and so they can
only thrive where there is a chemical
bounty on which they can feast
there are rudimentary food webs large
protists of the apex predators hunting
down mindless herds of bacteria in
places the eukaryotes begin to form
rough multi-cell associations
but for the most part they are rare
individuals among a thriving multitude
of simpler forms
and that multitude is beginning to find
its way out of the oceans too sustained
by rainfall and wind-blown dust the
first cyanobacteria mats begin to
colonize fresh water and terrestrial
habitats
for the first time in earth's history
there is the glimmer of green
on the land itself
the world that persists for a billion
years of the mesoproterozoic
is
by all accounts
an unpleasant one
a hot steamy atmosphere is sustained by
laughing gas the land surface hulks
immobile on one side of the world while
the ocean marches across entire
hemispheres uninterrupted by islands or
ice
that ocean is a stagnant putrid expanse
rimmed with black sludge and emitting a
sulfurous stink that spans the globe
living things are still microscopic held
back and ghettoized by geochemistry
an extraterrestrial visitor at any point
in this period would be forgiven for
turning back
and these conditions persisted
for a billion years
and so it has taken scientists the last
25 years to uncover just how so little
could happen to so much for so long
and why
things did
eventually
change
[Music]
if a year ticked by each second
then all of written history would fit
into a little under an hour and a half
homo sapiens themselves have been around
for three and a half days and it will
have been two years since the extinction
of the dinosaurs on this time scale the
entire history of the earth would span
140 years and the boring billion
throughout which the earth and life
stood still
would last
31.
22
of the entire history of the earth is
defined
by stasis
in this time had it occurred in a more
recent more normal era humans could have
evolved from boneless sea creatures
twice over
there could have been two or three
traditional supercontinent cycles and
several hundred switches between icy and
balmy climates
but there was not
these are fluctuations that define the
more recent and familiar geological
epochs but there are no fluctuations to
mark the passage of time through the
boring billion
only the inexorable and imperceptible
advance of years
if fluctuation and variability is the
norm then the constancy of the
mesoproterozoic is an exceptional state
that requires an exceptional explanation
all of earth's systems are
interconnected so changes in any one
component have the capacity to transform
the rest and affect conditions worldwide
so perhaps the remarkable stagnation of
climate continents atmosphere oceans and
life needs only one driving factor
one major obstacle to change that keeps
the rest of the planet
in a rut
[Music]
geologists suspect that the giant
spanner that brings earth's surface
processes to a halt lies not on the
surface itself but underneath it even
2.7 billion years after the planet's
formation its interior is still
surprisingly hot
heat left over from the violence of its
accretion plus the radioactive decay of
heavy elements trapped in the core
contribute to an internal furnace whose
swelter has no escape
the entire mantle is superheated and the
asthenosphere the semi-solid layer that
solid crust essentially floats upon is
especially torrid even though the earth
is cooled enough for mantle currents to
begin to jostle the solid plates of the
surface this still isn't the plate
tectonics that we recognize when
colliding plates are subducted beneath
one another they pass through the hot
asthenosphere and are melted to a
viscous shadow of their former selves
before they plunge too deeply there is
no descending slab inside the mantle to
pull the rest of the plate down after it
and without this gravitational tug the
rest of the plate stays put
it is a process mirrored in millions of
teacups across britain every day
a dunked biscuit soaked too long in hot
tea will lose its lower half to the
depths of the cup while the undipped
portion still floats in place
and so without the pull of a subducting
slab the plates of the colombian and
then rodinian supercontinents simply
didn't have the energy to tear
themselves apart the land surface stays
the same and as a consequence
everything stays the same with no new
rifts or mountain ranges there is no new
rock exposed for weathering no new
sources of nutrients or drawdown of
reactive gases
no movement of the landscape to promote
glaciation or change in sea level to
offer fresh habitats for burgeoning life
the carbon cycle slows
to a trickle and is stuck
another surprising
extraterrestrial factor may have also
helped to dampen any fluctuating
feedbacks in the earth system during
this time
usually when climates begin to warm they
see more evaporation from ocean surfaces
leading to greater cloud cover which
blocks incoming sunlight to help reverse
the initial warming
but there is another source
that has been linked to the formation of
clouds
cosmic
rays
as powerful beams of radiation cross
space and bombard our planet they help
to create the seeds around which clouds
form
so more cosmic rays leads to more clouds
around the earth the effect is small
enough to be masked by normal
fluctuations in global weather and
climate
but over a cosmic time scale like the
boring billion these celestial forces
have a chance to shine
astronomers believe that the
mesoproterozoic coincided with a period
of very low star formation in our
galactic neighborhood as a result of our
movement between the milky way's spiral
arms
fewer stars being formed makes for fewer
cosmic rays and as a result
fewer clouds
the earth's natural feedback to
continually warm climates is
for this eon crippled by galactic events
and so it remains
for a billion years
the only hope of escape from this
interminable rut is the cooling of the
planet itself
heat from the interior radiates out into
space at a lead and pace and eventually
the superheated asthenosphere cools when
subducting slabs can stay cool and
attached to the plates on the surface
for longer plate tectonics shifts into a
new gear
with more force behind them they have
the strength to pull apart and rodinia
shatters
compared to the langer of the preceding
billion years the planet transforms in a
geological heartbeat
continents scatter the ocean basins are
reformed and mixed the composition of
the air transforms and the climate cools
for the first time in an eon permanent
ice persists throughout the warmest
summers
and before long that ice stretches
almost to the equator the tedium of the
boring billion is broken
and earth and life erupts into frenzy
change once again
[Music]
it is important here to remember a
central tenet of scientific reasoning
the absence of evidence does not
necessarily translate to evidence
of absence
the fact that scientists haven't found
human-like neural circuitry for pain in
animals like fish
doesn't necessarily mean that fish can't
feel pain
the absence of any contact from
extraterrestrial civilizations doesn't
necessarily mean that aliens don't exist
and so just because we don't find
evidence of change during the boring
billion doesn't necessarily mean that
change didn't happen
simon poulton was a young phd student at
the university of leeds when roger buick
and martin brazier are uncovering the
truth of the boring billion taking a
break from his field studies into the
stinking black mud at the bottom of
modern day oceans he attended a european
geoscience conference in vienna topping
the bill for the day's talks was donald
canfield with his theories for a
stinking black ocean that persisted for
a billion years
and now more than 20 years later
professor poulton is head of
geochemistry and earth history at the
university of leeds having traveled with
canfield to the northern shores of lake
superior and finding evidence to support
the stinking canfield oceans
but he also uncovered an even more
important truth
the boring billion
wasn't actually that boring after all
his studies into the ancient rocks of
this period revealed that oxygen levels
in the oceans while low did in fact
fluctuate over more familiar geological
time scales
not only that but the seemingly hard
stop in the development of life is
blurring at the edges as paleontologists
uncover more and more fossils dating
from this once barren period frenzied
activity of more recent earth processes
has done an excellent job of obscuring
the true record of the past
rocks that are nearly 2 billion years
old are scarce and those that survive
have been buried crushed cooked and
deformed it takes the tenacity and
expertise of specialists like simon
poulton to extract the truth from such
an altered and fragmented record
now he and many other mesoproterozoic
experts have had two decades of staring
at the dullest time in earth's history
and they have found the boring billion
to be just as exciting as any other
error there is for example evidence of
volcanic activity the upwelling and
outpouring of magma in the australian
and canadian shields led to the
formation of brand new land surfaces and
reconfiguration of the rodinian
coastlines plate tectonic movements may
have been stifled but they weren't
absent entirely and the collision of
continental fragments saw the creation
of mountain ranges to rival the andes
the scars of the grenville orogeny still
cut across the american continent from
mexico to labrador and extend across the
atlantic into scotland
the climate may not have been as
unvaryingly warm as was originally
thought either
the transient nature of ice does not
necessarily lend itself to leaving
permanent records in the rocks and when
these rocks have been so racked by time
any event smaller than a global ice age
could be missed or erased entirely
in fact as recently as 2020 evidence of
debris dropped from rafted icebergs was
discovered in one billion-year-old lake
bed rocks from scotland
so there was ice at this time and we
will find hints of it if we know where
to look
[Music]
as for life there is no denying that
eukaryotes didn't take off at the speed
of their bacterial cousins but there
appears to be more variety out there
than paleontologists assumed 20 years
ago
like the transient ice small scale
cellular organisms are vanishingly
unlikely to leave a trace in such
ancient rocks
fossils of multicellular algae several
tens of centimeters in length have been
recovered from chinese rocks more than
one and a half billion years old fossils
of complex eukaryotes have been found in
the same billion-year-old scottish lakes
as the iceberg drop stones
there is complex life out there if we
know where to look
and in fact the relative stability and
toxicity of the boring billion may have
been exactly what these more complex
cellular organisms needed in order to
take the stage eukaryotic cells first
came about when two prokaryotes contrive
to collaborate with one coexisting
inside another so that both parties reap
the benefits of their specialist skills
but modern eukaryotes contain much more
complexity than the simple cooperation
of two bacteria they contain intricate
machinery and inter-reliant processes
whose evolution is harder to explain
but with a thousand million years of
unchanging conditions these new cells
have a chance through low stakes trial
and error to sort things out while the
abundant prokaryotic masses keep the
balance eukaryotes can experiment and
figure out the elaborate dance of sexual
reproduction
[Music]
so at first glance the vast span of time
between the sudbury impact 1.8 billion
years ago and the global ice age 0.8
billion years ago certainly seems to be
uneventful but even as professor martin
brazier named it the boring billion he
didn't really believe it was dull
he was fascinated by it and inspired a
new generation of geologists to be
fascinated by it too
although nothing appeared to happen from
one long moment to the next the world
that emerged at the end of the boring
billion was very different to the one at
its start
unprecedented geological stasis was the
necessary calm before the evolutionary
storm priming the machinery of earth and
life for the explosive change that was
to come
we may have never evolved
without it
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth
don't forget to like and subscribe
and leave a comment to tell us what you
think
i will see you
next time
[Music]